and Meg why are you on the couch you
know you're not supposed to be on the
furniture you be clear about this thing
where people are like what's the voice
that you do for me it's this and I am a
proud hat owner shut up Meg this is the
voice guys I have no skills I pitch it
sometimes now because I have since aged
myself due to life and uh that's it
that's my that's my skill set but when I
got it at 15 it was just my voice which
was a little bit
um younger all in all I think that is
you know half the time Meg doesn't talk
she's like kind of like in the
background that gets farted on or sat on
get off me so if I have dialogue I'm
really happy
foreign